[Music]
foreign
ERS rise of the Beast just got a new
trailer and the most exciting part of it
is in the terracons or the scorpionox or
the Maximus either it's the appearance
of Unicron for the first time in live
action as a fully seen entity well the
one from The Last Knight was only seen
as horns emerging out from the Earth but
this one here in Rise of the Beast will
blow your mind so let's get into his
Origins his designs and also his size as
well as abilities in comparison to the
other one from the Beavers movies so
let's get to it let's start with his
Origins from the last night according to
the movie the last night Unicron was
once an eternal entity that existed in
the very early days of the universe
however his insatiable hunger caused him
to consume everything in his path
including other planets and even Stars
this caused him to grow in size and
power as well until he became a living
planet capable of transforming into a
gigantic robot but this was never seen
unicron's inert body formed the Earth he
was always cybertron's an enemy but
knowledge of his location was lost to
time for more than 4.5 billion years he
arrested and life gradually emerged on
the surface it wasn't until quintessa
discovered unicron's resting point and
planned to drain him of his life Essence
to restore Cybertron then he began to
wake up and his sixth horns sprouting in
various locations around the world
okay let's see about his Origins from
Rise of the bees this upcoming movie
however takes the beginnings of Unicron
back to the original storyline so back
where it all started he was created by a
god-like entity called the one who
sought to balance the universe by
creating a force of chaos to counteract
the force of order represented by his
brother primers Unicron was created as a
planet-sized entity capable of
transforming into a gigantic robot he
quickly became a powerful and
destructive force consuming entire
planets left and right for energy and
leaving behind nothing but destruction
and Chaos he then became the main threat
to the universe and was opposed by
various factions of Transformers
including both the autobots and the
maximals in this movie
so let's discuss his design from the
last night so in the Beavers Unicron
wasn't really seen in full he was stated
to be the entire planet Earth or at the
very least its core so what you see is
what you get with the only visible
elements of the planet sized robot were
his six horns that appeared randomly in
different places and with shiny metallic
as well as crude in appearance Unicron
in The Last Knight looks like planet
Earth well because he is planet Earth
and this is the main reason as to why
that continuity was abandoned was
because how in the world would you save
the world while fighting against the
world which is actually a Transformer
get it no it's all right no one does
so let's look at his design from the
rise of the bees well in this trailer we
get five distinct scenes of Unicron each
one showing five different aspects of
him in the first one we see him as a
massive planetary object that possesses
solid rings around his main body it all
appears to be a metallic ball with a
pair of moon sized claws at two ends as
well as a moon size opening in the
middle which unlatches up to reveal a
glowing fiery mod ready to devour and
consume in another scene we see the
mouth from the ground perspective well
inside a planet's atmosphere looking up
on the third and fourth parts we see the
glimpse of his main henchmen called
Scourge Legacy and reminiscent of the
Silver Surfer and in attendance before
Galactus as his Herald I bet Scourge
will have the same role coming to Earth
through Herald the arrival of Unicron
who has two metallic eyes so therefore
there is also a good chance we might see
a bipedal robotic form of him later in
the movie but that's just speculation
and the last scene also showed him in
his planetary form again at the time
when he was consuming a planet
so what about the sizes of these
unicorns well from the bavers the
maximum extent of Unicron size would be
the diameter of the Earth itself maybe a
little bit less when excluding the cross
so here he would be over 12 000
kilometers or 7500 miles across his
minimum estimate his size would go with
the theory that he was just a hiding
robot within the planet and he would be
the size of the core of the earth which
is roughly 2 400 kilometers of 1500
miles wide this iteration would have
been one of the smallest in the entire
franchise because Unicron is always
thought to be the biggest or one of the
biggest fictional monsters ever
well rise of the Beast does Justice in
the trailer of the rest of the bees he
is clearly bigger than planets and was
explicitly stated to be bigger than
planets
um but that is kind of misleading and
vague since planets differ in size with
Mercury being only less than 5000
kilometers while Jupiter is nearly 140
000 kilometers across so if we go by
movie logic which kind of standardizes
planet sizes as around earth size then
Unicron would be twice or even three
times bigger as seen in one of the
scenes of the trailer the one which it
was about to devour a blue Oceanic World
which is roughly the size of Earth and
that world also has Saturn like rings
around it so let's give him an estimate
of 30 000 kilometers in diameter in
planetary form and also let's speculate
that if he transforms into a robotic
being then he would be around a hundred
thousand kilometers in height which is
wow so lastly let's talk about his
abilities in both the last Knight and
the right eyes of the bees to be honest
we know little to nothing about his
capabilities and powers from the Beavers
since they were never shown but what we
do know is that Unicron here could
hibernate for billions of years which
means he isn't a chaotic forever
starving robot that consumes planets
left and right in the rise of the bees
however we can clearly see him about to
devour a blue planet then sucking up the
material from another more Barren will
and then on its way to Earth for the
same purpose he can travel into Stellar
space obviously and has the ability to
transform as we have seen a part of his
face bearing two robotic humanoid eyes
which means there is gonna be a head and
if there's a head there is a body this
means only one thing in the end we are
going to see a galactus-sized robot
finally in live action around the size
of the celestials from the movie
eternals but not as lame as them
so that's it I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam